hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of our newsletter readers Dina
who is a single mom she's opening up a
spa business and is scared and one of my
advice on what to do to make your
business a success so Dina congrats on
starting the business very exciting very
scary times it's your first business I
know as a lot of kind of jitters to get
that going for you I think the best
thing you can do is go out and start
getting customers even if you haven't
lost your business start getting pre
customers so get people excited about
what you're doing get people interested
in in your business and the services
that you're going to offer and start
building a little bit of momentum around
your company the next thing I try to do
is try to keep my costs low so startups
the reason why most people will go out
of business as they run out of money so
do you need to have a physical location
even the start can you go to people's
homes as an example as a way to get your
business started or can you start in
your own home as well get people coming
in start earning some cash flow if
you've already got your location then
can you start with services where maybe
you don't have to go out and buy the
most expensive equipment so maybe there
are some services that you can do more
cheaply it's just your time so basically
try to keep your costs as low as you can
start bringing in some money and then as
the money comes in you can afford to
invest it back into the business that
continue to grow the last thing probably
the most important thing is your service
based business so provide awesome
service so whatever you do in your spa
business make it really awesome right
you have to find ways to stand out from
every other spa company because there's
tons of companies out there who provide
the same services that you do so you
have to find different ways to stand out
so be the best at whatever you do for
your target market that way you get
repeat customers you get referrals
coming back to get people who are
interested in you keep coming back buy
more stuff from your business there may
be an opportunity in terms of cash flow
to be able to sell some kind of
membership or subscription-based so it's
a spa service that they may need once a
month as an example you can sell that to
them up front for a discounted fee and
you know have some cash flow coming in
pretty early on but it all starts with
having services that are unique and
different from everybody else and really
servicing your customers so they love
working with you they want to come back
tell their friends it's a huge
experience to come sadena at her spot so
I hope that helps good luck with the
business if you have more questions let
me know I'll try to help as much as I
can I wish you tons of luck I hope you
do really well with that business for
everybody watching a video I'd love to
hear you have to say about it too what
do you think Dina should do please leave
a comment under the video give it a
thumbs up if you liked the video and
we'll see you in the next episode
you